- It is time for Drew's News,
your daily sighting of the
majestic good news whale.
(mimics water whooshing)
Right out the blowhole.
- Was that your blowhole?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Oh yeah, I figured it out.
- It was.
- Okay. I got it.
- Well, with me at the
desk is the best co-pilot
in the business,
Ross "Your Awesome" Matthews.
- Hi, everybody. Hi!
(audience applauds)
Blowhole.
(mimicking water whooshing)
- First up today in the
headlines, she is a culinary icon.
- Mm hmm.
- Julia Child is back.
- Julia!
- Oh yes!
And Food & Wine reports that
the Food Network is launching
"The Julia Child Challenge,"
which is the competition show where chefs
will recreate Julia's classic recipes.
It's literally gonna
be like a side by side
and it's all for a chance for the prize
to go to a French cooking school.
Take a look.
- [Voiceover] They'll
cook alongside their hero.
- Mm, this really yummy.
- [Voiceover] Who also
started as a home cook.
- I just love to muck
around in the kitchen.
- [Voiceover] And found
her calling later in life.
- Welcome to "The French Chef."
I'm Julia Child.
- [Voiceover] They'll cook
in a kitchen, just like hers.
- It's so close to the real thing
- [Voiceover] With the same
ingredients that she used
that made her.
- Voila!
- Julia.
- Sill alive.
- Uh huh.
(audience cheers)
I mean, if this isn't appointment TV,
I don't know what is.
It starts tonight on the
Food Network, but wait,
there's more if you need it,
because HBO Max is launching
their own scripted series,
"Julia," about the
visionary leap that she took
onto television in 1963.
And it's starring Sarah Lancashire
and David Hyde Pierce as
Julia's husband, Paul.
Ross.
- I know
- I can't.
- I can, I'll tell you.
I love Julia Child,
Julia, for many reasons
but there's something about Julia.
She made you feel like you
could embrace the mistakes
in the kitchen and hello.
- Hi.
Rebel homemaker.
- I mean, I am a human,
living, walking, breathing mistake.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Just.
You know, I am! I'm all
about the messing up.
- Also, there's something
about her I relate to.
I mean, she sounded different.
She looked different than
everybody else on television.
And that's why we fell in love with her.
And there should be more people
that don't fit the mold television.
(audience applauds)
I love that about her.
- You're so right, Rossy.
One time I had breakfast
with Meryl Streep.
I swear this is a true story.
- Hold on.
I'm gonna need CPR real
quick. Anyone wanna?
- I know, and she, I got there
and she was already there.
I was like, "Of course,
Meryl beat me there.
Oh, I should have been waiting
for her, it's Meryl Streep."
And I came in and she had her script open
and she was like, "Yeah, I'm just doing,
learning this dialect for my
next character, Julia Child."
And I was like, "I think
it's gonna be amazing."
- [Ross] Yeah, and she
was nominated for an Oscar
for it.
_ If that isn't, like,
the go-to movie when it
comes across your scroll
of your TV guide.
- Oh my gosh.
- Every time I will dip in.
- I can't go past it,
no matter what,
I have to watch it.
- "Julia and Julia."
It's the greatest movie.
Amy Adams, Stanley Tucci,
So Julia for everything
- Well Meryl, you were
amazing in "Julia and Julia."
We can't wait for all this
Julia Child love coming up.
(upbeat music)